contrary to your common movie villain
the walking dead are simple primal and
animalistic still there are all kinds of
complex mysteries surrounding their
abilities and tendencies that tend to
get glossed over or go completely
unexplored when we think of zombies we
tend to think of shambling undead
corpses that ravenously hunt for human
flesh all day and all night
a habit that will continue unabated so
long as they're still hooked up to those
all-important brains are you with us so
far sure it's disturbing but it's also
just kind of confusing sometimes
we'll see zombies that are deformed
beyond recognition but are still quite
snappy and energetic and sometimes
highly decomposed zombies can still move
with the same BIM and vigor they once
demonstrated in gentler less zombified
times in fact some zombies seem to move
even faster than when they were alive as
zombies began to outnumber humans well
that's when you have to cut all
emotional ties these idiosyncrasies can
be somewhat explained when a film is
constrained to a very specific timeline
I am Legend is set three years after the
initial outbreak and it doesn't stray
too far from there allowing for some
continuity in regards to those dastardly
dark seekers but in shows like The
Walking Dead the issue of deterioration
has become a challenge
much like the act of watching the
walking death has become a challenge to
give you an example let's compare and
contrast here are some terrifyingly
low-key zombies from season 1 of The
Walking Dead
[Music]
and here are some zombies from season 8
of The Walking Dead
yeah they look a little worse for the
wear but they move like they've hardly
aged a day
so what exactly is their secret Olay
vitamin enriched to fight seven signs of
aging in four weeks skin looks up to ten
years younger as the years pass us by
and the seasons drag on and on it raises
an obvious question how and why are
these jerks still moving around at
virtually the same speed as when they
first turned into zombies anyone
every movie seems to have its own origin
for the zombie plague if they bother to
explain it at all
but none of them try to answer the most
basic question what exactly goes on in
these zombies heads when it comes to
brain function there's absolutely no
consistency in the world of these cold
clammy bloodthirsty creeps some zombies
move with superhuman speed and are
capable of effortlessly lifting people
into the air with their bare hands
meanwhile other zombies are seemingly
incapable of even taking a brisk
afternoon stroll for every goal-oriented
zombie with Drive and determination
[Music]
there's a whole mess of zero ambition
zombies who can barely keep it together
no dreams no ambition
[Music]
this raises more puzzling questions what
level of brain function do these undead
shambling nightmares operate on are some
zombies smarter than others and if these
zombies are technically dead how do they
have any brain function in the first
place any insights sorry here's
something else that really bugs us some
zombies have the wherewithal to be fast
as hell bounding about like young
gazelles other times they're just
shuffling along slow as snails and twice
as slimy like these boring zombies if
there really are a few rudimentary
thoughts still floating around inside
these zombie brains where exactly is the
line drawn do all the same rules apply
to mean-spirited zombie monkeys what
about majestic zombie horses
some zombies are apparently Mensa
material remember that scene in World
War Z when the undead hordes built a
towering zombie ladder to scale the wall
yeah that's not the kind of thing you
could just build on pure instinct even
for a zombie movie that type of behavior
is kind of a stretch here's something
else about zombies that we're just
supposed to accept because we're never
given any kind of rational explanation
at all
why do zombies always want to eat human
beings it's so excessive we're not
talking about some desperate compromise
made in order to survive on a lifeboat
not the zombies don't like to go on a
sailing expedition every once in a while
when it comes to zombies and their love
of human flesh we're talking about a
culinary preference like no other
whenever someone turns into a zombie it
usually only takes a matter of seconds
before they start munching on the
nearest person they can find
why do zombies like human flesh and not
say fast food Walker in a moment of
weakness why can't your standard grade
zombie just engulf a bag of Cool Ranch
Doritos like everybody else frankly this
unending quest for fresh human flesh
gets to be rather OneNote and what's
worse these unstoppable killing machines
are often willing to devour the nearest
member of their family in the name of a
good old-fashioned blood meal
enough is enough can we please get some
concrete answers as to what makes these
unspeakable monstrosity stick
[Music]
apparently when humans die and become
zombies their first instinct is to
gather in herds at least that's the
takeaway from pretty much every show
about these grim ungodly ghouls sure
there's still the occasional solo
zombies straggler that pops up from time
to time that's usually just for the sake
of a jump scare the really serious
threat arrives when a gigantic group of
zombie deadbeats stumbles onto the scene
[Applause]
whether we're talking about an intimate
group of like-minded zombies gathering
in a safe environment or a mega herd of
zombies come to eat everyone's brains
this very instant the burning question
remains the same why is this supposed to
be the natural behavior of zombies in
the first place
they're not getting more food this way
just look at them they're going to be
hungry all the time if they insist on
traveling in these kinds of numbers
because zombies are greedy and selfish
weird
whether it's the creatures and I am
Legend or those horrific monsters in
Zombieland these creatures almost always
have come to a herd mentality not that
anyone ever really bothers to explain
why the closest we ever get to a
concrete answer is this for a moment
let's turn our attention from the undead
to the living at their root zombies are
a bona fide medical curiosity that cause
uncontrollable outbreaks and exhibit
horrific symptoms that worsen over time
some shows like The Walking Dead never
confront the quarantine issue by making
the zombie virus some sort of blanket
sickness that everyone eventually tracks
but more often than not containing and
controlling the outbreak is the core
plot point in a zombie film take the
movie quarantine for example so here's a
question if a zombie outbreak affects
continents and eventually the entire
globe what happens to the people who
live on remote islands sure it's easy to
rule out the bigger players like Great
Britain after all the film 28 days later
takes place on that particular island
nation but what about smaller more
out-of-the-way locations like that
faraway Island in the life-affirming ly
awful film House of the Dead does Hawaii
remain an island paradise or does
everybody who live there also get
infected in the event of a zombie virus
outbreak
what about Madagascar is this cute
little guy gonna get turned into a
zombie
often times a zombie outbreak is
shrouded in secrecy at the beginning of
the story in order to ratchet up the
tension the protagonist is often left
completely in the dark regarding the
increasingly undead state of the world
around him or her sometimes it seems
like the zombie apocalypse took place
while a healthy chunk of the world was
getting some good old-fashioned shut-eye
sure that totally works for zombie
stories that came out before social
media was a thing but films and
television shows that take place after
the rise of Mark Zuckerberg needs to
start taking Facebook into account let's
get real here what if this woman was
loitering around your neighborhood
imagine if these ghouls spontaneously
erupted from the soil of your local
cemetery wouldn't someone try capturing
these precious moments on their
smartphone wouldn't a few folks decide
to share the spectacular sites on
Instagram what we're trying to say here
is the idea of a zombie apocalypse that
isn't thoroughly trumpeted on social
media is patently absurd not to mention
totally unrealistic here's another
aspect of zombie anatomy that's hard for
us to wrap our heads around they
basically live off of nothing all the
time and seemingly forever but even
after they've just enjoyed some human
flesh they still act like they're
totally starving they even act that way
after a gosh-darned bonafide feeding
frenzy like all these zombies literally
just ate
this zombie didn't even finish eating
the nice old lady and now he's making
moves on this other dude such a waste
what we've learned from all of this is
that zombies are basically impossible to
satisfy is there any rhyme or reason to
this zombie bloodlust let's think
rationally about it for a second if 80
or 90% of the population are turned into
zombies it makes sense that fresh human
flesh would be a hot commodity indeed
but a few years down the line it would
be nearly impossible for these zombies
to find any food to shovel into their
bellies they evidently don't need to eat
people in order to survive they're dead
so why are they always so pumped to be
eating everybody anyway and yet there
they go
skulking around in search of another
bite but if zombies are willing to snack
on the occasional dead deer like this
gentleman here why the obsession with
eating people and after they've chopped
on an unlucky human do zombies ever
crave something ice-cold and refreshing
to wash it all down with you can see the
problem here these guys must be
extremely dehydrated once again the
question of nutrition becomes
particularly sticky with long-running
shows like The Walking Dead all these
years later
how are the walkers even moving at this
point we're all familiar with the site
of a bloody zombie in fact no one even
bats an eye at the site anymore
but what about all those uninfected
people who accidentally get covered in
zombie blood The Walking Dead literally
has their heroes cover themselves in
zombie guts to sneak through the undead
zombie gridlock undetected how on earth
is that safe we know that a zombie bite
is almost always fatal and will almost
definitely turn you into a zombie even a
zombie scratch can become a health
hazard mock wait
so how and why is it okay to be covered
in fresh zombie blood why don't those
humans get infected they're bound to
have a little scratch on them somewhere
with the zombie blood to get in right in
the end it's never going to make total
sense these are all just movies about
silly made-up monsters check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]